hi I'm Sarah I'm ANCA and we're not
scientists definitely not sciences but
we look like them today because we are
going to be trying kids science
experiments as adults yes did you do a
lot of science experiments as a kid I am
not familiar with the language of
science I have I took chemistry once and
I failed it I like actually failed it I
actually hated chemistry as well oh no
and this is kind of like exactly what my
name is I made it anyway Inga's here I'm
challenging her we're gonna see who can
do besides experiment correctly and then
if all else fails we're bringing in an
expert okay
so I consulted with someone via email
who gave us the ingredients we'd need to
build a volcano without instructions
you're gonna need white vinegar food
coloring baking soda cold water room
temperature water
I'm empty you saw the bottle and of
course a homemade volcano but this is a
competition
and we can't see each other so we're
going to need to block us off yeah can
we wake up we get a separation please
this is a competition to fail less
miserably that's the real competition
that's happening so this is in place all
that I know is that the explosion
happens at the end so there must be one
ingredient that causes okay and we only
get one shot and I can't look at my
phone don't look at your phone and guy
are you ready let's go
[Music]
I don't really know why we have so many
measuring tools why does it matter if I
don't actually know how I'm gonna
measure it should I keep this for
aesthetic purposes why are they two
different types of water I feel
confident that the water is not what's
gonna make the explosion so I'm gonna
put the water in the bottle first can I
cook a lot right so I know that for
cleaning you combine these two
ingredients so I know there's like some
reaction going on here I just heard her
say you combine to a creek and fill the
holes once they are so I'm gonna add
this in I don't know how much I hope
this isn't like actually explode now
what the water temperature has to matter
no I don't think this is right we're
making a volcano so I think I gotta put
bread in there oh wow that's a lot of
wine a too much butter how much water
were supposed to add but this is gonna
be my last thing should I test it out if
you're gonna do a mini one before this
here again I don't know I'm gonna much
how do I need it's not gonna do anything
yo what you need you just do anything
happen but right so this is gonna go in
here you're like Inga's ahead of me now
and I don't know I don't know how to
deal with it it's the only thing I have
it at it kind of free ballin
I'm not even measuring I just don't know
what else to do
we're doing it
[Music]
oh okay okay you can't see the look it's
um it's fizzy
it's orange maybe it's like a soda
bottle and you need to kind of there we
go look at that now it's looking good
just needs okay all right we could take
we can take this divider away but it's
supposed to shoot up I don't know what
well yours is doing way better than mine
do you think you're cooking expertise
helped yeah I think because I knew that
these two together I was saying that
like sometimes you just I use this
mixture to scrub pots and pans mm and I
know I get like some frothiness and I
also know dish soap get this you bubbles
so I just combined it I didn't know how
much though I just literally the last
thing you added vinegar okay good that
two didn't work out for me I must have
had my measurements wrong I think it
could be better still could maybe be a
little better let's clean this up and
let's bring in the experts all right
okay so obviously we couldn't really do
this so we're bringing in a science
expert sure professional hi did you make
this mmm I'm sorry how old are you I'm
907 I thought we were having a science
expert I am the science expert I've done
so many volcanoes oh wait a minute
23 that's one of the the one at MIT this
is my homemade a volcano and I actually
painted it a couple days ago this looks
incredible this is made of styrofoam but
you can also use paper mache dirt just
don't lose paper that's side that just
stopped yeah of course we would never
they look lame Marisol what's a volcano
a volcano is a cone shape mountain with
a vent that connects to the molten rock
layer below the earth when a volcano
erupts the molten rock is driven up by
gas oh okay then demet
so that's basically what we're creating
here but this is different than an
actual looking egg not that right yeah I
know that of course an adult I've never
been this excited let's get started yeah
all right first combine the water white
vinegar dish soap and food coloring into
an empty soda bottle I'm gonna measure
out 400 milliliters of white vinegar
adult thing I can do probably the only
one you can do
sounds like ping well that smells
horrible now we're going to measure 100
milliliters of cold water and add dis
show so he need 10 of milliliters of
dish soap mmm I mean I don't eat dish
soap I don't know I I hope not now add
your food coloring and a separate cup to
make baking soda slurry combine water
and baking soda make yours into a slurry
did I make mine into a slurry
was that a slurry well you need a 50
milliliters of water it's going through
the room-temperature water and then you
add the baking soda 15 milliliters does
it react yet no no now when you mix it
around to make sure it's a slurry
it's like paste mmm yummy and you
explained the chemical reaction to me
look what's going on baking soda and
vinegar create a gas called carbon
dioxide oh and run mix it foams and
explodes that makes sense now it's
almost time to do the experiment but
first we need to set up the locking up
oh I don't know why we didn't think of
this don't want to be messy yeah of
course of course you don't want to be
messy I feel like I should put some
dinosaurs out this is cute huh
okay I'm gonna make this slurry a bit
more fun I'm gonna add some food
coloring this is a very important step
because you want this slurry to be very
mixed not a nice color it's very pretty
finally pour the baking soda slurry into
the soda bottle and step back quickly
actually that worked
yeah we worked 23 other times on it okay
okay well I'm so sad I couldn't get it
to do that when I tried it now we can do
it and you could do it at home you you
don't come back
what about Inga can she do it sure thank
you oh you were right you had to jump
back that's pretty fun we'll see you
next time when we try another kids
science experiment and I guess gets
shown up by a kid how are you again 9
turning 10 I enjoy and already so wise
oh and ER what are we doing already so
bye
[Music]